c'est bon on est parti bon bonjour à
tout le monde
vous avez failli et rang des bons le on
va donc aujourd'hui attaqué le la
sixième partie de cette affaire qui va
concerner d'énergie nucléaire
on va recommencer comme d'habitude en
s'intéressant aux dictionnaires ou plus
exactement en essayant de bien définir
ce dont on va parler alors l'énergie
nucléaire on va commencer par utiliser
une lapalissade puisque la pallice
souvent et forte utile quand on parle
d'énergie
c'est une énergie qui est dérivé de ce
qui se passe dans le noyau d'un atome
vous savez quand les atomes il ya de
l'énergie est utilisée pour la liaison
entre les ducs léon et l'énergie
nucléaire va consister essentiellement à
essayer de capter une partie de
l'énergie que les noyaux contiennent à
la fois sous forme d'énergie liaison est
tout simplement sous la forme de la
masse des particules qui le composent
il ya deux manière d'essayer d'utiliser
cette énergie
la première consiste à utiliser un gros
noyau qu'on va casser en petits morceaux
et vous allez voir pourquoi est-ce qu'on
peut récupérer de l'énergie en passant
la deuxième version celle inverse c'est
à dire ça consiste à essayer de réunir
plusieurs petits morceaux en un gros et
vous allez aussi voir pourquoi est ce
que on peut récupérer l'énergie dans ce
genre d'opération et dans les deux cas
de figure on va profiter de cette petite
équation que vous connaissez
probablement c'est-à-dire de
l'équivalence entre énergie et masse et
en fait on va profiter d'un défaut de
masse qui apparaît lors de la réaction
et qu'il a donc fournir de l'énergie
alors ce défaut de masse qui fournit de
l'énergie en fait qui consiste à se
déplacer sur ce diagramme qui représente
l'énergie dit
par nucléons en millions de briques tron
volt c'est ce que vous avez sur leur
donner ici en fonction de la masse
atomique du noyau que vous êtes en train
de regarder alors faites attention la
masse atomique c'est pas le nombre de
protons il s'agit bien du nombre de
nucléons c'est l'ensemble nucléaire plus
proton vous payez que quand on est sur
des éléments très léger l'énergie
liaison a tendance à ne pas être très
élevé au fur et à mesure que on va vers
le fait remarquer le dévent le plus
stable que nous ayons l'énergie de
liaison augmente
et puis après quand on continue à
grimper dans les masses atomique et bien
l'énergie de liaison par nucléons a
tendance à diminuer un petit peu qu'est
ce qui se passe une fois qu'on a vu ça
eh bien on peut se dire que si on arrive
à faire aller un noyau léger si on
arrive à rapprocher suffisamment des
noyaux légers pour qu'ils aient envie de
s'assembler on va former on va partir de
new dans lesquels l'énergie de liaison
n'est pas très élevé pour arriver à un
noyau dans lesquels l'énergie de liaison
est beaucoup plus élevé c'est-à-dire un
noyau plus stable et vous savez que
aller à la stabilité c'est toujours
quelque chose que les systèmes beaucoup
faire en physique est là il va s'agir de
fusion alors en fait si vous regardez la
masse des noyaux initiaux que vous
prenez et la matinale des noyaux que
vous obtenez vous avez comme je disais
tout à l'heure un défaut de masse quand
vous allez de l'un vers l'autre et ce
défaut de masse va se retrouver pour
partie dans l'énergie de liaison accrue
du noyau qu'on a formé et pour partie
libérée sous forme d'énergie cinétique
ou de rayonnement c'est à dire de photos
alors quand vous allez des noyaux légers
vers des noyaux plus lourd c'est la
fusion une fusion dont vous allez voir
dans pas longtemps qu' on est très
contents qu'elle existe et puis vous
pouvez aller dans l'autre sens c'est à
dire aller des noyaux lourds vers des
noyaux plus léger et à ce moment on
parle de fission ici vous avez
schématiser quelque chose sur lequel je
reviendrai dans le courant de secours
qui est ce qui se passe sur un noyau
d'uranium qui reçoit un neutron à la
bonne vitesse c'est-à-dire à la bonne
énergie et qui va mal le dise
et se casser en deux derrière alors la
fission qui est la plus couramment
utilisée dans les réacteurs actuels et
celle de l'uranium mais vous allez voir
que là aussi il n'y a pas que cet
élément qui soit doté de cette propriété
dont cruel vous avez ici une courbe qui
vous donne la stabilité en fonction la
stabilité atomique en fonction du nombre
de nucléons que vous avez dans l'atome
enfin dans le noyer et tous les effets
les réactions nucléaires
suivent la propension qu'ont les noyaux
a essayé d'aller vers le sommet de cette
courbe encore une fois la stabilité
maximale et obtenu pour le noyau du fer
ce qui veut dire que le système dans
lequel vous avez atteint une stabilité
absolue ccir tout l'univers été
transformé en un bloc de fer
l'absolument en plus rien à en tirer
alors quelque chose c'est important
c'est que vous voyez que sur la courbe
que je viens de projeter les énergies de
liaison et donc les énergies qu'on va
mettre en jeu quand on va modifier le la
manière dont les nucléons sont assemblés
dans un ou plusieurs noyaux atomiques
est typiquement de l'ordre de quelques
millions d'électronvolts donc une
réaction nucléaire ça met en jeu par
apple ou par noah lieu plus exactement
une énergie qui est typiquement de
l'ordre de grandeur du million
d'électron volts
c'est ce que je vous avais déjà dit au
cours du premier cours
un million que même en train de digérer
vous savez que c'est un million de fois
plus grand qu'un donc c'est typiquement
des énergies qui sont un million de fois
plus élevé hamas identique que l'énergie
qu'on va avoir dans une réaction
chimique
alors je prends l'exemple de la
combustion du carbone donc de
l'oxydation du carbone eh bien vous
prenez un atome de carbone et vous
l'oxydé l'énergie qui va être mise en
jeu qui va être libérée plus exactement
par l'oxydation du carbone qui est là
pour le coup un réarrangement d'orbital
des électrons ces quelques électrons
volts si vous arriviez à fusionner les
atomes de carbone pour faire que quelque
chose d'un peu plus lourd et bien à ce
moment vous avez plutôt d énergie de
quelques millions de
volt qui sont mises en jeu une autre
manière de dire encore la même chose
exprimé en des termes j'allais dire plus
plus grand public c'est de dire que dans
un gramme de plutonium par exemple
d'uranium
enfin l'uranium sa fiche est pas en
totalité mais un gramme de plutonium on
va dire fissionner en totalité vous
libère autant d'énergie que la
combustion d'une tonne de pétrole
vous pouvez retenir cet ordre de
grandeur assez que l'énergie nucléaire
par unité de masse
elle libère des quantités qui sont un
million de fois supérieure à l'énergie
chimique
alors une fois que je vous ai dit ça
vous comprenez que ça va pas de gérer
exactement avec les même dispositif que
ça va pas mettre en jeu des masses qui
sont exactement équivalente
on travaille sur des masses et qui est
des volumes qui sont beaucoup plus
petits une chose qu'il faut commencer
par dire c'est que l'énergie nucléaire
est totalement indispensables à la vie
mais vraiment extrêmement indispensables
à la vie puisque c'est grâce à l'énergie
nucléaire que nous avons ceux ci et si
nous n'avions pas ceci est bien la fois
nous ne serions pas dans cette salle
pour nous parler de l'énergie nucléaire
ou pas nucléaire vous avez là une très
belle photo de l'observatoire spatial
s'appelle sceau du soleil alors vous
voyez que je vous donne des nouvelles
fraîches
puisque ça c'était la tête qu'il avait
hier à 19h20 ailleurs à 19h20 il allait
bien vous voyez donc supporter y rayonne
tout va très bien
donc cette énergie nucléaire vous allez
voir qu'elle est à l'origine de la quasi
totalité des autres formes d'énergie et
même la totalité si on inclut les
étoiles passé de toutes les formes
d'énergie que nous utilisons aujourd'hui
sans l'énergie nucléaire de la
génération des toiles qui a précédé le
soleil y aurait pas non plus la planète
terre la planète terre existe elle est
constituée d'éléments qui ont été forgés
dans le creuset des étoiles plus
anciennes d'abord on a fusionné
d'hydrogène pour donner de l'hélium puis
on a fusionné deux
l'yonne pour donner des éléments plus
lourds du carbone de l'oxygène et
caetera et ainsi de suite jusqu'à des
noyaux extrêmement lourd
l'uranium dont on a abondamment parlé au
cours de secours on le doit pleurer
actions qui ont pris place dans la
génération des toiles qui a précédé le
soleil donc ces étoiles elles ont
terminé leur existence elles ont envoyé
des poussières un peu partout dans
l'univers et une partie de ces
poussières se sont retrouvés autour du
soleil en formation ce sont condensés et
on fait la planète sur laquelle il fait
si bon vivre
aujourd'hui donc l'énergie nucléaire ou
du soleil et vous allez voir encore une
fois qu'elle fournit toutes les formes
d'énergie ou à peu près que nous
utilisons sur terre ou des toiles plus
ancien est quelque chose qui permet et à
la terre d'exister et à la vie de
prendre place sur terre alors entre un
tout petit peu plus dans le détail à peu
près toutes les énergies renouvelables
sont la conséquence directe de l'énergie
solaire une première forme d'énergie
renouvelable
c'est par exemple la biomasse la
biomasse est le résultat de la
photosynthèse la photosynthèse c'est
directement l'énergie du soleil une
deuxième forme d'énergie renouvelable si
c'est l'hydroélectricité pour que vous
ayez d'hydroélectricité il faut que vous
ayez un cycle de l'eau il faut que le
système climatique se charge parce que
c'est quand même très pratique il le
fasse de remonter l'eau en altitude
via l'évaporation de condenser l'eau sur
des reliefs élevé puis derrière de
concentrer l'eau dans des barrages on
verra ça plus tard
mais donc sans cycle de l'eau il y
aurait pas d'hydroélectricité et sans
soleil il y aurait pas sans alimentation
de la machine thermique qu'est la
machine climatique vous auriez pas cycle
de l'eau même motif même punition
le vent est directement dérivé de
l'énergie solaire le vent est le
résultat de la convection atmosphérique
et ça n'existerait pas sans énergie
solaire on peut bien évidemment utiliser
la chaleur en direct ou platement le
rayonnement en direct soit pour faire de
la chaleur soit pour faire de
l'électricité tout ça on en parlera
livre prochaine après les énergies
fossiles comme je voulais expliqué lors
d'un cours précédent c'est également de
l'énergie solaire sauf qu'elle est un
peu plus vieille que l'énergie qui a
fait pousser l'arbre qui à 50 ans ou un
siècle puisque celle là il a plutôt 50
millions d'années ou 300 millions
d'années mais
c'est aussi de l'énergie solaire donc de
la fusion et puis ça a été un peu
chauffé dans la croûte terrestre par la
géothermie il se trouve que la
géothermie est le résultat de la
radioactivité naturelle des roches
encore de l'énergie nucléaire est bien
évidemment monsieur de la palisse est
encore dans ce court d'énergie nucléaire
qui consiste à casser les noyaux
d'uranium en deux elle est tout à fait
nucléaire donc et si on rajoute le fait
que la terre et la lune ont été formés
par les éléphants sont fortes sont
constitués d'éléments qui ont été forgés
dans le creuset des toiles anciennes et
bien vous rajoutez la géothermie et
l'énergie marémotrice parce que pour
l'énergie marémotrice il vaut mieux
avoir une
et bien tout ça c'est le résultat de
réactions nucléaires plus ou moins
anciennes donc n'importe quand entre il
ya quelques minutes pour ce qu'on reçoit
aujourd'hui et il ya quelques milliards
d'années où quelques où ce sera quelques
gros milliards d'années dont les
éléments forgés par la génération
précédente le soleil donc tout nucléaire
voilà on veut si la nuit si l'énergie
nucléaire n'existait pas nous
n'existerions pas non plus c'est
évidemment pas comme ça que la majeure
partie de vos concitoyens voient
l'énergie nucléaire il voit pas ça comme
le berceau de l'humanité en général ils
ont plutôt une opinion qui est piloté
par d'autres considérations et en
particulier quand on parle d'énergie
nucléaire on va simplement voir les
applications humaine de cette énergie
c'est à dire le fait que dans des
machines qui sont conçus pour ça nous
soyons devenus at soit à casser des
noyaux lourds soit pour de brèves
périodes de temps et sont probablement
ça soit commercialement exploitables
géant vers la fin de secours à fusionner
deux noyaux plus léger ce que voit donc
les êtres humains c'est la manière dont
les hommes ont géré cette technologie
particulière et la première fois qu'ils
ont vu à grande échelle comment était
géré cette technologie particulière ça a
donné ça et ça évidemment pour passer
très rigolo on trouve de ce père même
que ça va pas recommencer demain matin
au pire la même perfectionné de
dispositifs et ça a donné ça c'est à
dire que les premières applications ou
de la fission de noyaux lourds ou de la
fusion
léger on les a vus à grande échelle
quand ça a fait boum
évidemment ce dont je vais vous parler
maintenant c'est essentiellement pas de
ça je vais vous parler de la manière de
produire de l'électricité
en attendant d'être autre chose avec de
l'énergie nucléaire avant d'en venir là
je vais finir la parenthèse sur le
nucléaire militaire
je vais pas vous en parler pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est que
comme toute application militaire je
n'en sais je ne sais rien dessus puisque
l'essentiel des applications militaires
sont couverts par le secret défense
donc je ne suis pas plus compétent pour
parler du nucléaire militaire que je ne
suis compétent pour parler de n'importe
quoi d'autre qui aurait qui serait dans
les cartons de la dgr ou de n'importe
qui d'autre et qui seraient couverts par
le secret défense
la deuxième raison c'est que rejeter le
nucléaire civil à cause du fait qu'il a
démarré avec des applications militaires
et quelque chose qui vous allez voir à
la fin de secours ne changerait
malheureusement pas grand chose à la
destinée du nucléaire militaire
parce que il vi après pro vie de son
côté avec des déterminants qui ne sont
pas ou très peu le fait qu'on ait des
centrales électrogènes et enfin si vous
regardez l'histoire des hommes
il faut malheureusement se rendre à une
évidence c'est que beaucoup de ce que
vous utilisez aujourd'hui dans votre vie
tous les jours à commencer par internet
à commencer par enfin commencer par
mettre dans des laboratoires militaires
cet art si c'est le côté obscur de notre
force qui fait qu' il ya beaucoup de
technologies qui sont aujourd'hui d'un
grand bienfait dans le monde civil qui
on donnerait envie dans des laboratoires
où on cherchait à s'en servir pour
zigouiller le plus grand nombre de
personnes possible et malheureusement
une fois qu'elles ont démarré comme ça
refuser leur usage civil ne modifie que
très peu il est encore une fois il faut
plutôt s'en plaindre que s'en réjouir
l'aah destinée militaire si maintenant
on parle de la partie civile
donc des applications nucléaires
et de la génération d'électricité avec
ce genre de dispositif eh bien vous avez
la résumer à grands traits ce qu'est une
centrale nucléaire électrogène points 2
il s'agit essentiellement de faire
bouillir des grandes quantités d'eau
sans avoir besoin de recourir aux
combustibles fossiles et pas trop cher
voilà c'est très exactement ça le une
centrale nucléaire c'est avant toute
chose une bouilloire très compliqué
c'est très compliqué parce que comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure on
manipule des éléments qui mettent en
oeuvre des densité d'énergie un million
de fois supérieur à ce qu'on manipule
qu'enfin aux éléments que l'on manipule
quand on fait brûler ou du gaz ou du
charbon ou du pétrole
sinon pour le reste c'est exactement
pareil vous partez d'un tacle
combustible là j'ai comparé par exemple
charbon et uranium
dans le premier cas vous prenez du
charbon va vous le faites brûler avec ça
vous chauffer de l'eau alex est vous
créer de la peur et avec cette vapeur
vous faites tourner un alternateur et
ainsi vous créer de l'électricité
et bien si vous prenez du radium c'est
exactement le même principe vous faites
fissionner de l'uranium
avec ça vous fait de la chaleur avec
cette chaleur vous faites bouillir de
l'eau comme le en fait qu'il a passé
dans le coeur du réacteur est radio
active c'est pas avec celle là en
général que vous attaquez on dirait que
l'alternateur mettez un échangeur pour
confiner la radioactivité dans ce qu'on
appelle un circuit primaire
et c'est avec un circuit secondaire qui
a reçu cette chaleur qui a été
transformée en vapeur que vous allez
attaquer un alternateur et frère de
l'électricité alors je vous dis une
chose qui avoue et peut-être qui pour
vous est peut-être une évidence mais je
vous assure que pour le grand public
scène n'est pas l'électricité est
produite avec une centrale nucléaire
n'est pas plus radioactifs que
l'électricité produite avec une centrale
à charbon
alors tout ça vous fait rire je vais
vous montrer tout à l'heure
justin justin sondages d'opinion je vous
assure que dans le grand public et je
reviens à ce que je vous ai dit la
dernière fois le grand public ça sera
vos clients ça sera le fournisseur saas
ravoux salariés safra etc 1
vous allez être dedans c'est pas des
gens qui vous seront étrangers et bien
pour le grand public
je suis en train de vous dire qui encore
une fois peu à vous vous sembler une
évidence c'est pas toujours acquis voilà
donc le site et qui sort d'un
alternateur de centrales nucléaires est
une électricité normale ordinaire on
pourrait dire derrière vous allez avoir
dans un cas comme dans l'autre des
résidus quand il s'agit du charbon le
résidu s'appelle descendre le résidu
s'appelle du so2 si vous avez du soufre
dans le charbon est le résidu s'appelle
du co2 qui est un déchet que nous
mettons dans l'atmosphère et qui produit
les effets que vous savez maintenant que
vous avez eu droit aux deux séances qui
porte sur la question en ce qui concerne
le radium et bien vous avez aussi des
résidus dont je vais vous parler ces
résidus s'appelle des déchets nucléaires
et il faut gérer
dans un cas comme dans l'autre vous avez
une machine thermique dont vous avez
besoin d'une source froide
dans un cas comme dans l'autre si vous
montrez un aéroréfrigérants un français
ils pensent centrales nucléaires si vous
montrez un aéroréfrigérants à un
américain il a pensé centrales à charbon
du reste pour ceux d'entre vous qui
viennent d'aix-en-provence
il ya des gens qui lui n'est qu'en
prolongeant la seule non personne de
marseille
ah bah voilà les deux marseillais vous
connaissez la centrale de gardanne oui
non au pied de la montagne
sainte-victoire enfants la voient très
bien du haut de la montagne sainte
victoire et bien la centrale de gardanne
qui est une centrale à charbon qui vient
d'être fermée à de très beaux 0 au free
gérant voilà le très bon machin comme ce
que vous voyez sur la droite et c'est
une centrale à charbon
donc le encore une fois la sauce froide
est quelque chose qui est absolument
indispensable dès que vous avez besoin
d'une machine thermique et c'est un état
propre au nucléaire du reste vous vous
rappellerez probablement ce petit
graphique que je vous avait déjà montré
qui était le passage de l'énergie
primaire à l'énergie finale et le
passage de l'énergie primaire à
l'énergie finale inclut notamment les
rendements de conversion de chaleur en
électricité quand l'énergie quand la
chaleur primaire est fourni avec de
chaleur avec du charbon pardon
chaleur et c'est avec du charbon ou du
gaz ou de l'uranium et ses pertes de
conversion font que n'importe quoi entre
50 et 80 % de la chaleur initialement
fournies dans la centrale sert à
chauffer les oiseaux dans toutes les
centrales thermiques entre la moitié et
80 % de la chaleur initialement produite
sert à chauffer les oiseaux c'est
valable quelle que soit la manière de
faire bouillir de l'eau en 2003 ça fait
maintenant cinq ans dont vous étiez un
tout petit peu plus jeunes mais
peut-être que vous en souvenez il ya eu
pendant l'été ce qu'on a appelé une
canicule c'est à dire une vague de
chaleur un peu intense et cette année là
l'opérateur national qui s'appelle edf a
demandé des dérogations pour faire
fonctionner les centrales électriques en
restant dans les rivières de l'eau plus
chaude que le seuil de tolérance
réglementaires auxquels ils avaient
normalement droit mais ils ont droit de
rejeter de l'oua je sais plus combien de
degrés et il avait exactement de faire
monter la température de la rivière à
chypre au même degré et il avait demandé
la possibilité de dépasser ce seuil d'un
ou deux degrés dans l'es13 dérogation
qui l'ont demandé il y en avait sept qui
concernaient des centrales nucléaires
dont la presse a abondamment parlé et si
ce qui concernait des centrales à
charbon dont absolument personne n'a
parlé donc la presse a retenu que les
centrales nucléaires réchauffer les
rivières en période de canicule
mais bien évidemment encore une fois
c'est vrai pour absolument n'importe
quelle centrale thermique avant de
rentrer dans le détail de ce que c'est
qu'une réaction nucléaire pour finir ce
petit panorama ce petit pas vraiment pas
bon introductif du nucléaire qui en fait
un certain nombre de pays qu'on pourrait
qualifier de pays industrialisés
vous avez ici je vous ai mis juste une
indication la part du nucléaire dans la
production électrique d'un certain
nombre de pays il ne s'agit pas de la
production en valeur absolue en valeur
absolue le premier producteur au monde
sait les américains mais les américains
comme vous pouvez le constater là ne
font que 20% de leur électricité avec ce
moyen simplement comme ils font un quart
de l'électricité mondiale
et bien avant pour cent d'un quart de
l'électricité mondiale chez les
américains ça fait beaucoup plus que 80%
de l'électricité française fois ça fait
pas beaucoup mais ça fait
significativement plus donc de o2 et aux
deux extrémités du spectre
vous allez trouver d'une part la france
qui effectivement dispose d'une
singularité qui est que 80 % de
l'électricité produite sur le territoire
il resterait à savoir si elle est
effectivement consommée sur le
territoire parce que vous savez que
maintenant est de plus en plus
d'interconnexions entre les pays mais
80% de l'électricité produite sur le
territoire est d'origine nucléaire
donc en deux quand il ya un
kilowattheure de produits sur le
territoire huit fois sur dix il sort
d'une centrale nucléaire avec
l'extrémité du spectre
vous allez trouver la chine hélas ici si
vous lisez les journaux vous vous
souvenez peut-être qu'il ya eu un grand
battage
il ya quelques mois je suis plus quand
exactement parce qu'il était question
que la france vendre quelques périodes à
lachine le nucléaire en chine ces deux
pour cent si ma mémoire est bonne ou 3
de la production électrique chinoise
à peine la peine d'en parler plus de 90%
de l'exercice de si loin des fêtes au
charbon vous avez voilà l'heure après
vous avez un certain nombre de pays
intermédiaires en europe les gens qui
sont des producteurs significatif
d'électricité nucléaire ou plus
exactement qui ont une part
significative du nucléaire dans leur mix
vous les avez sur la partie gauche dont
vous avez la belgique si on excède les
pays de l'est à la belgique la suède la
suisse
voilà je dirais dans notre entourage
proche les pays qui ont la plus grande
part d'électricité nucléaire dans leur
mix vous avez l'ukraine où est situé le
fameux réacteur de tchernobyl dont je
vous parlerai tout à l'heure
et puis d'ailleurs vous voyez vous avez
dpi beaucoup de pays européens ont un
peu de nucléaire l'allemagne en à 30%
pour le moment les grands bretons en ont
20% les espagnols en ont plutôt 17 à 17
à 20% et c est bien évidemment le set
par elle est amenée à varier à l'avenir
elle peut baisser elle peut monter une
chose intéressante à savoir je vous
épargne le graphique c'est que l'europe
est considérée par les spécialistes du
nucléaire comme la zone géographique où
là où la région du monde où le jeu le
plus ouvert pour le nucléaire dans les
quinze ans à venir
c'est à dire que c'est c'est difficile
de savoir si ça va augmenter ou baisser
par contre dans toutes les autres zone
du monde c'est parti pour augmenter
alors maintenant qu'on a fait les choses
à l'envers c'est à dire parler du
nucléaire avant de définir
on va commencer à s'intéresser à ce que
c'est que l'énergie nucléaire qu'on va
rentrer un peu dans les détails on va
commencer par parler de la fission pour
l'excellente raison que c'est la manière
d'exploiter l'énergie nucléaire
qu'aujourd'hui les hommes savent
maîtriser de manière industrielle un
appel inconscient on dit qu'il est si si
si il est capable de se casser en deux
morceaux en deux ou plusieurs du reste
deux gros morceaux et des petits dans
quelques cas très rares cette fiction
est quelque chose qui se produit
spontanément c'est à dire que la
désintégration radioactive du noyer au
lieu d'émettre un électron en positon
une particules alpha et sert à croître
jusqu'à 102 voilà c'est comme ça qu'ils
réseaux sont pleines d'instabilité ça
marche aussi chez les couples mais c'est
pas fréquent est moins fréquente chez
les couples parisiens
le deuxième cas de figure qui peut
arriver
ce que l'absorption d'un neutron à la
bonne énergie rendent le noyau instable
et alors là par contre il se met à 6
youn est très rapidement derrière et par
exemple l'uranium 235 m beaucoup
fissionner de cette manière vous prenez
de l'uranium donc avec 92 proton et 235
9 et ont voulu envoyer
à neutrons à la bonne vitesse il absorbe
et il va fournir deux nouveaux noyaux
plus petit évidemment quelqu'un de tron
et du rayonnement gamma
alors si on regarde ça d'un peu plus
près donc ce noyau qui est apte à se
casser en deux une fois qu'on lui a
envoyé un de tron est un noyau fissiles
il fait qu'ils reçoivent l'uranium
c'est pas vrai pour tous le noyau mais
l'uranium il faut qu'ils reçoivent un
neutron qu'on appelle un autre on
thermique
c'est à dire qu'il est grosso modo en
équilibre avec son milieu à quelques
centaines de degrés celsius donc son
énergie soit inférieur on va dire un
électron volt en europe de grandeur et à
ce moment il va fournir la station de il
à fournir des produits de fission qui
sont des noyaux qui seront animés d'une
énergie cinétique donc une partie de
l'énergie libérée par la fission c'est
l'énergie cinétique des produits de
fission
il va fournir des neutrons qui sont des
neutrons beaucoup plus énergétique que
le neutron qui lui a permis de
fissionner puisque ces deux troncs là
ils ont une énergie qui est typiquement
de l'ordre de 2 un peu plus un peu moins
millions d'électron volts et du
rayonnement gamma
alors là je vous ai pas qualifiés x et y
mais voilà un exemple de fission
possible de l'uranium
c'est qu'ils fournissent du krypton et
du baryum et kate neutrons voilà c'est
un exemple mais il n'est pas obligé de
donner toujours du krypton et du baryum
il peut donner d'autres choses alors on
va on va rester un peu sur cette
relation les voir ce qu'elles signifient
à pratiquer si on veut faire des
réacteurs qui soit capable d'exploiter à
le réacteur 5 ans parce que ça réagit un
qui soit capable d'exploiter cette
énergie on va commencer par s'intéresser
la production les produits de fission
ils sont l'objet d'une courbe en forme
de dos de chameau n'ont pas de gros
madère vous avez ici la distribution des
produits de fission après une réaction
de fission concernant l'uranium dont
vous allez avoir un premier pic de
concentration des jeunes formés aux
alentours de 90 2
masse atomique là dedans vous allez par
exemple trouver le krypton vous allez
par exemple trouver le strontium l'un
des isotopes la des produits de fission
classique dans la fission de l'uranium
c'est le strontium 90 production qui est
lui-même radioactifs
et là vous allez trouver le 16e elliott
qui sont aussi pour ceux d'entre vous
qui ont déjà un peu regarder ce genre de
sujet des produits de fission très peu
en dans la fission de noyaux d'uranium
et qu'on va retrouver dans les déchets
radioactifs et puis dans l'environnement
si jamais cette affaire a le mauvais
goût d'aller se promener ailleurs il ya
par contre des noyaux qui ne sont faits
que en toutes petites quantités ceux qui
sont ou à les voiliers entre 110 et 120
de masse atomique
et puis en a qui sont passés du tout
donc ce genre de réaction ne libère pas
de noyau de masse atomique inférieur à
70 et ne libère pas de noyau de masse
atomique supérieur à 160
tous ces produits sont en général
radioactifs donc vous êtes dans le coeur
du réacteur
le noyau d'uranium a été cassé en deux
vous vous retrouvez avec vos deux
produits de fission
d'abord ils ont de l'énergie cinétique
et ensuite ils sont radioactifs ça veut
dire que eux mêmes vont contribuer un
rajouter des particules en circulation
dans notre réacteur ils vont émettre des
électrons ils vont émettre les positons
ils vont émettre des neutrons ils vont
en voir enfin ils vont ils vont émettre
de particules alpha pardon
vont ils vont émettre un certain nombre
de choses ou bien ils ont la faculté
d'absorber des neutrons donc vous avez
des produits qui commence à se balader
dans le coeur de votre réacteurs et dont
vous devez tenir compte dans le pilotage
de la réaction de fission
la deuxième chose que vous obtenez donc
en sortie d'une fission ces deux neutres
ou et comme vous avez vu ces neutrons
yvon à une vitesse bien trop importante
pour être capables eux même d'engendrer
une réaction de fission derrière donc on
va avoir besoin de ralentir alors les
ralentir ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que l'on va les faire se
cogner contre des particules qui ont une
masse pas très différente de celle d'un
neutron donc ça veut dire des atomes
dont le noyau n'est pas très élevé en
masse atomique des petits noyaux pour
que exactement comme avec un système de
boules de billards les neutrons scania
successivement au petit noyau et
finissent par perdre de l'énergie comme
ça vous savez que si vous avez une
collision parfaitement élastique avec un
objet d'une masse infinie parfaitement
immobile et bien la particule qui se
cognent record avec une énergie
cinétique identique à celle qu'elle
avait en arrivant pour qu'elle perde de
l'énergie cinétique
il faut que l'objet dans quel état tu
puisse se déplacer et plus il peut se
déplacer facilement puis les petits
et puis elle va perdre d'énergie
cinétique c'est exactement le même
principe alors dans le réacteur vous
avez donc d'être fission qui se produit
et vous allez mettre ce qu'on appelle un
modérateur qui peut parfois être le cas
le porteur du reste c'est à dire le
fluide qui est chargé de récupérer la
chaleur qui va contenir des petits
noyaux et qui va qui vont permettre de
ralentir les neutrons qui se baladent un
exemple typique de modérateur qui est
aussi un caloporteur c'est le parce que
dans le vous avez des noyaux d'hydrogène
d oui c'est ça des noyaux d'hydrogène
s'est pas lourd et puis même les noyaux
d'oxygène s'est pas encore extrêmement
lourd un autre exemple de modérateur
c'est graphite
le graphite est composée d'atomes de
carbone le carbone avec 12 de masse
atomique
c'est encore des noyaux qui sont
relativement léger et que vous et qui
peuvent servir à ralentir de neutrons
voilà des fois le modérateur et le
caloporteur ne sont pas les mêmes
mais en général c'est en fin de droits
sans qu'un nombre de dessins de
réacteurs c'est la même chose et puis
vous allez également avoir des éléments
qui joue bien sans qu'on leur demande de
rien ou bien à la demande vont être
capables d'absorber de neutrons alors
les éléments qui sans qu'on leur demande
rien à voir est capable d'absorber les
deux troncs c'est les produits de
fission par exemple certains produits de
fission sont ce qu'on appelle notre fils
c'est à dire que pour passer à neutrons
but trouve que ça a bon goût et ils le
mangent et puis vous avez certainement
lourd par exemple quand vous faites
fonctionner un réacteur dans lequel vous
avez mis à la froide l'uranium 235
difficile et de l'uranium 238 ce que
vous trouvez aussi dans leur dans
l'uranium naturel l'uranium 238 lui il à
l'aptitude à absorber à neutrons sans
rien faire voici vous allez voir qu'il
fait quelque chose devait plus tard
voilà mais en attendant il absorbe crax
neutrons n'est plus disponible pour une
réaction de fission donc vous allez
avoir des neutrons rapides ils vont être
modérée en en un des plus grands que 1
ils vont être modérée par des noyaux
légers qui se trouve dans le coeur de
votre réacteurs et une partie va être
absorbée sachant que le but du jeu c'est
que pour une réaction de fission vous
vous retrouviez à l'arrivée avec très
exactement 1
et quand je dis très exactement 1 c'est
vraiment quelque chose auquel les
réacteurs sont extrêmement sensibles
donc un réacteur nucléaire se pilote
avec reviennent décimales derrière le 1
c'est quelque chose où on se relaie ça
comme le lait sur le feu
il faut que vous ayez exactement un
neutron thermique à la rigueur si vous
avez un plus haut de six jeunes et que
vous laissez le truc sans contrôle même
exactement ce qui se passe dans une
bombe nucléaire
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé à
tchernobyl
j'aurais pas le temps vous parler en
détail les caractéristiques techniques
de l'accident mais en fait il se trouve
que le cumul d'un défaut de conception
sur le réacteur est d'une bêtise faites
par les opérateurs à la demande de
hiroshi abouti à une réaction qui a
divergé qui a fait de ce qu'on appelle
une excursion puissance c'est à dire que
le système s'est retrouvé hors de tout
contrôle dans un état dans lequel une
fission a produit plus de l'un d'eux
tron thermique et le truc hein qu'est ce
que tu as posé vous êtes ce cas face
qu'à exposer c'est l'hydrogène mais il
s'est emballé vous avez bien évidemment
la chaleur qui est dégagée dans cette
affaire la chaleur c'est l'agitation qui
est communiqué aux atomes du modérateur
et aux atomes du caloporteur parle par
le flux neutronique évidemment par les
chocs avec les produits de fission qui
sont animés eux aussi d'une énergie
cinétique
donc voilà un peu comment ça marche à
l'intérieur d'un réacteur
c'est sur le principe très simple et en
pratique extrêmement compliqué je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure que il y avait
également des neutrons qui pouvait être
absorbée est en fait ils vont faire ce
qu'on appelle des transuraniens bon un
noyau d'uranium difficile en
l'occurrence de l'uranium 238 absorbe à
neutrons puis c'est une désintégration
bêta puis une deuxième désintégration
bêta est comme ça ils grimpent le long
de la classification des éléments pour
faire des éléments dont le nombre de
protons est plus élevé que celui de
l'uranium
donc vous avez dans votre réacteur là si
vous le faites fonctionner à de
l'uranium enrichi dont il ya du 235 et
si vous avez juste du 235 c'est une
bombe atomique dont vous pourriez pas
faire un réacteur pour en faire un
réacteur il faut que vous ayez du 235
n'est pas trop et donc il vous reste
également dû 238 quel autre isotope de
l'uranium naturel qui est présent à peu
près à 99 3 % si ma mémoire est bonne
dans l'uranium naturel et donc il est
présent dans votre réacteurs et celui là
il est notre fils donc voulu envoyer un
de tron à la bonne vitesse de sucre à
qu'il absorbe les neutrons et il se
transforme en uranium 239 qui va finir
par se désintégrer est formé du
plutonium donc là il n'a pas dissuadé
il a juste observé neutre par contre il
se trouve que plutonium lui est fissile
dont vous avez des produits secondaires
qui apparaissent dans votre réacteur qui
peuvent être soit de mangeurs de
on soit éventuellement des produits
fissiles eux mêmes et puis vous obtenez
également du rayonnement gamma dans
cette affaire contre lequel il vaut
mieux se protéger
on vient donc de voir que l'uranium 238
été capable d'engendrer la fabrication
d'un nouvel élément fissiles exactement
je n'ai pas encore dit mais c'est ça on
va voir par double double désintégration
bêta
le plutonium exactement comme l'uranium
le plutonium 239 et avec lui tous les
isotopes ans père du plutonium peine
fissionner c'est à dire que de nouveaux
si on leur envoie un neutron à la bonne
vitesse
ils sont capables de se couper en deux
avec des produits de fission
vous avez donc en ce qui concerne
l'uranium 238
une caractéristique qui est que qu'on
appelle non pas d'être fils il me d'être
fertile
c'est à dire que au lieu d'envoyer un de
tron on envoie 2 et à ce moment on
obtient quelque chose qui se casse en
deux et de l'énergie d'accord engrais
pour exploiter l'énergie de fission de
l'uranium ou bien vous avez un fusil à
un coup
c'est l'uranium 235 ou bien vous avez un
fusil à deux coups c'est l'uranium 238
le premier coup le transforme en
plutonium est le deuxième coup avec deux
désintégration bêta intermédiaires et le
deuxième coup va le faire fonctionner
sauf que le neutron qui va permettre à
au plutonium de fissionner lui il doit
pas avoir la même énergie que celui qui
permet à l'uranium de fissionner il doit
aller voter plus vite doit être beaucoup
plus énergétiques
il doit en gros avoir une énergie delà
du million d'électronvolts ça ça vous
explique pourquoi les réacteurs
nucléaires qui sont capables d'exploiter
l'énergie du plutonium
on les appelle souvent des réacteurs à
neutrons rapides quand le quand le
dessin du réacteur c2 permet etc
j'allais dire de fonctionner
essentiellement avec du plutonium dans
la réaction de fission
on les appelle des neutrons des
réacteurs à neutrons rapides ou des
réacteurs rapide des éléments certes il
vous en avez deux dans la nature
donc là je vais vous parler de l'uranium
238 à neutrons plupart de nos enfants
vous avez également le thorium 232 qui
est un élément fertile et qui lorsqu'il
prend à neutrons à la bonne vitesse dans
un réacteur
là aussi vous faire avec juste une
désintégration bêta
nous parlons d'un faux départ dont vous
faites de l'uranium 233 qui est lui fit
side alors l'uranium 233 et sicile mais
il a une demi vie qui est beaucoup trop
courte pour qu'on en trouve dans
l'uranium naturel
je vous rappelle encore une fois que
l'uranium naturel est un uranium qui a
été formé dans la génération des toiles
qui a précédé la terre donc vous ne
pouvez pas trouver dans l'uranium
naturel de produits qui est dès 2010 de
dix mille ans ou même d'un million
d'années vous ne trouvez que de produits
qui ont quelques milliards d'années
comme de visite c'est typiquement le cas
d'uranium 238 parce que sinon ils ont
été fermées il ya trop longtemps pour
que l'on puisse en trouver dans la
croûte est ce cette caractéristique qu'à
20 ou plus exactement les noyaux fertile
de pouvoir engendrer des noyaux fissiles
dans le cou romaine de la réaction
nucléaire qui fait qu'on appelle les
réacteurs qui exploitent ces éléments-là
des réacteurs surgénérateurs en fait ils
sont pas surgénérateur il serait plutôt
régénérateur en d'autres termes la
réaction de fission entretient la
fabrication de nouveaux combustibles à
partir d'un matériau fertile c'est ça le
principe de réacteurs surgénérateurs
c'est que vous avez un matériau
simplement fertile et la réaction de
fission entretien en période de les dire
l'apparition de nouveaux matériaux
fissiles ils sont pas vraiment sûr
générateurs si on regarde la chronologie
des appareils qui permettent d'exploiter
cette énergie nucléaire
l'histoire a commencé en 1942 avec la
pile de fermi alors la pile de fermi
elle n'avait pas vraiment une vocation
électrogènes elle s'inscrivait comme
vous le savez probablement dans le cadre
de la course à la bombe qui a été
initiée par les amériques
dans le cadre du manhattan project et
elle avait une puissance de 0 5 watt
voilà donc c'était une pile vraiment au
vrai sens du terme
un peu comme un peu comme une pile de
lampes de poche mais ça suffisait en
l'occurrence pour ce qu'ils avaient
besoin d'en faire c'est quand même un
truc qui faisaient quelques mètres cubes
pour 0 5 watt
les premiers réacteurs électrogènes en
france qui est une taille significative
sont apparus dans les années à la fin
des années 50
les premiers le début de la génération
actuelle ceux qui sont actuellement
utilisées dans le parc français c'est
plutôt le début des années 70 alors ici
le numéro fait référence à la puissance
électrique du réacteur en question
ça veut donc dire car et 900 c'est un
rédacteur qui vous crachent 900
mégawatts électriques de puissance
nominale et à cause du rendement des
centrales nucléaires qui est grosso modo
de l'ordre du tiers
ça veut dire que la puissance thermique
qui est libérée dans le coeur du
réacteur c'est près trois fois ça donc
c'est à peu près de 2,7 giga watt crête
ça veut dire réacteurs à eau pressurisée
ça veut dire que le cas le porter à
l'intérieur du coeur c'est de l'eau sous
pression
voilà c'est ça que ça veut dire et c'est
un caloporteur qui fait aussi le
modérateur comme je voulais expliquer
tout à l'heure la génération la plus
récente exactement la version la plus
récente des réacteurs actuellement en
service dans le parc français s'appelle
le m4 et on considère qu'on est toujours
dans les réacteurs de deuxième
génération
après vous avez là ce qu'on appelle la
troisième génération
il n'y a pas de révolution conceptuelle
par rapport à la génération précédente
c'est on va dire de l'amélioration
continue de l'amélioration continue
significative mais ça reste de
l'amélioration continue donc on brûle un
peu mieux le combustible qui se trouve
dans le coeur la sécurité est un peu
augmenté on est c'est enfin voilà ça
fait un peu moins de déchets
il n'y a pas de ya pas de changement
significatif en termes de dessin ça
c'est le p r donc un des monstres est
donc une tête de série pardon est en
construction en france ainsi qu'en
finlande et enfin je vous parlerai un
peu après de ce qu'on appelle la
génération 4 c'est à dire ce qui est
actuellement dans les planches à dessin
des industriels qui construisent des
réacteurs nucléaires
parce que là il commence à y avoir des
ruptures significatives en termes
conceptuel qu'il n'y avait pas dans le
cadre de l'opr alors un réacteur peut
fonctionner ça a besoin de combustible
c'est pas un combustible qui brûle mais
enfin c'est quand même un combustible et
hongrie voilà comment ça fonctionne
l'histoire commence dans une mine
d'uranium
une nina c'est un dépôt c'est une
concentration que vous avez est une
formation géologique en fait un que vous
avez quelque part dans la croûte
terrestre est à dire que par le jeu de
la formation des continents il ya des
endroits où vous avez plus d'uranium que
d'autres et où vous allez avoir envie
d'aller creuser prendre ce qui vous
intéresse les c'est ce qui vous
intéresse pas de côté et passer à
l'étape suivante qui est que quand vous
retirez une peine de quelque chose d'une
mine d'uranium
en fait tu veux quelque chose qu'on
tient énormément de trucs qui ne sont
pas du radium et à la concentration de
quelques pourcents de l'oxydé d'uranium
il ya que ça qui vous intéressent donc
il faut commencer par séparée
mécaniquement l'oxydé d'uranium de tout
le reste qui nous intéresse pas puis
vous allez en faire une espèce
d'agrégats que dans le jargon des gens
de la 2 2
je veux dire qu'ils font de l'extraction
minière d'uranium qu'on appelle du
yellow cake et c'est cet agrégat que
vous allez faire rentrer dans une espèce
de road
la ronde est la suivante dans votre
radium naturel comme je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure vous avez deux isotopes qui
sont présents de manière significative
l'isotope 238 nucléons qui fait 99,3 %
est l'isotope 235 qui fait 0 7%
vous avez un dessin de réacteurs
nucléaires dans le monde
proposé par les canadiens qui s'appelle
le camp du dans lequel vous êtes capable
de rentrer le d'uranium naturel tels que
vous n'avez pas besoin de l'enrichir
vous le faites directement rentré dedans
il ya ça c'est un avantage par contre le
gros inconvénient c'est que vous êtes
capable de faire ressortir le
combustible alors que le réacteur est en
cours de fonctionnement et ça c'est
quelque chose qui rend le réacteur
extrêmement proliférant parce que c'est
une manière très facile de fabriquer du
plutonium 239 qui est la matière
première pour fabriquer des bombes
atomiques
donc le la majeure partie des gens dans
le monde fonctionne avec un système
différent
le système consiste à enrichir l'uranium
c'est à dire avec des procédés qui sont
essentiellement des procédés physiques
qui se base sur le fait que l'uranium
238 est un tout petit peu plus lourd que
l'uranium 235 à séparer les deux
isotopes pour avoir un peu plus de celui
qui vous intéressent qui est fissile
dans le matériau à l'arrivée alors et
pratique
le procès d'aujourd'hui tient la corde
et ce qu'on appelle
l'ultracentrifugation vous prenez votre
uranium vous l'associez à ce qu'il faut
pour que ça devienne gazon il ya du
fluor dedans mais j'ai plus exactement
c'est ce rituel 6 si ma mémoire est
bonne et vous mettez ça dans des
centrifugeuses
ou plus exactement des deux dispositifs
dans lequel vous allez faire tourner le
gaz avec l'idée que là et vous avez
d'uranium 238 immigra un peu plus vite
vers la périphérie et avec un système
des coqs qui ramassent le gaz à la
périphérie
vous allez enrichi à 20 côté en uranium
238 donc
l'autre côté par contre courant
d'uranium 235 et puis vous faites passer
votre gaz dans des milliers de
dispositifs comme ça en cascade et à
l'arrivée vous avez un gaz qui est
significativement enrichi en isotope 235
pour la sortie qui vous intéressent
évidemment puis après vous refaites de
la chimie et vous re transformer ça en
oxyde d'uranium
évidemment dans le quai ce que je veux
dire dans le processus vous avez aussi
produit ce qu'on appelle le l'uranium
appauvri c'est-à-dire un du radium qui
est très enrichi qui contient quasiment
plus d'uranium 235 et qui ne contient
quasiment que de l'uranium 238
alors on en fait des choses diverses on
peut tirer sur les ennemis avec mettre
ça dans l'acquis des bateaux parce que
c'est un métal extrêmement lourd ou le
laisser soigneusement de côté parce que
cela matières premières qui permettra de
faire fonctionner des surgénérateurs
demain peut-être s'il ya un déploiement
significatif
une fois que vous avez votre matières
premières vous allez faire des
assemblages de combustible alors les
assemblages de combustibles en pratique
ce sont des crayons c'est à dire des
gaines en métal dans les têtes vous
mettez des pastilles d'oxydés d'uranium
et ses espèces de château d'assemblage
que vous allez placé dans le coeur du
réacteur
au milieu du caloporteur ça va rester
quelques années dans votre réacteurs le
temps que la réaction de fission
consomme à peu près tout l'uranium 235
que vous aviez ni dans votre assemblage
et ont sorti vous retirez donc les
assemblages une fois qu'ils ont vécu
dans le réacteur pendant quelques années
donc les opérations de chargement et
déchargement c'est un peu plus compliqué
que pour une centrale à charbon et ça
explique aussi que vous ayez besoin
périodiquement sur ce genre le
dispositif d'opérations de maintenance
que vous devez planifier à l'avancé
et si le moment où vous avez planifier
votre opération de maintenance il ya une
partie des centrales des voisins qui
sautent où qu'ils aillent canicule où il
ya un hiver froid ou je sais pas quoi
et bien vous pouvez pas mobilisé la
centrale instantanément pour faire
l'électricité dont vous auriez besoin ça
ça fait parti des faiblesses du système
c'est que vous devez planifier alors
qu'ils voulaient bien organisé c'est pas
grave vous devez planifier le moment où
vous allez arrêter votre centrale et
quand vous l'avez arrêté c'est pas pour
c'est en général pas pour une heure vous
sortez votre assemblage une fois que il
a été il ay là il a fait son travail
et là vous allez l'envoyer dans un
endroit vous avez le traité à la le
traité ça veut dire que vous récupérez
ce que vous avez à l'intérieur des tubes
est derrière vous avez deux options
la majeure partie des pays choisissent
de prendre ce que vous de ces espèces de
tubes h et de les mettre dans un
container et déstocker dans un endroit
en attendant de voir plus tard donc ça
c'est par exemple l'option prise par les
américains les américains souhaitent
sortir les assemblages des centrales
nucléaires et les stocker sous la halle
yucca mountain en disant ça c'est un
déchet ça nous intéresse plus et puis
vous avez l'option qui a été prise par
les français les japonais sauf qu'il
faut faire ça chez nous et les anglais
et ils font ça chez eux pour partie qui
consiste à dire je sors le combustible
usé de l'assemblage de crayon je
récupère ce qui est récupérable à
l'intérieur et vous allez voir quoi est
ce qui n'est pas récupérable et qui
n'est pas très radioactifs
je le stock en surface dans un coin et
ce qui n'est pas récupérable et qui est
extrêmement radioactif
j'en fais des blocs de verre vitrifiés
et ça je l'aimé à la hâte pour le bras
en attendant éventuellement de les
enfouir à bure par quelques centaines de
mètres de fond ce que ce que font les
français donc c'est que en sortie de ce
qu'on appelle leur traitement mais qui
en fait devrait être dit traitement
c'est simplement un traitement c'est de
récupérer le plutonium qui s'est formée
dans l'uranium avant à partir de
l'uranium 238 parce que ce plutonium est
un fils il on va le mélanger aux
combustibles nas pour mettre ça dans des
réacteurs qui vont être capables de
manger c'est ce mélange d'uranium 235 et
de plutonium 239 avec cette petite
subtilité technique que comme vous
l'avez vu c'est pas des neutrons à la
même vitesse qui font fissionner les
deux noyaux
donc c'est des réacteurs ce qui les
réacteurs qui mange le mox là le mixed
oxyde ses deux réacteurs qui
nécessairement sont gérés un petit
vraiment de ce qu'ils mangent juste de
l'uranium 235 une fois que je voudrais
montrer pardon ce petit diagramme vous
comprenez que s'il n'y a pas d'émission
de gaz à effet de serre en direct dans
le fait de casser des noyaux d'uranium
en deux par contre vous en avez un peu à
côté
en plus beaucoup on va voir vous en avez
dans l'industrie minière ah bon parce
que pour sortir le minerai d'uranium de
terre il faut comme dans n'importe
quelle exploitation minière des gredins
peur avec des grosses roues et gros
tractopelle etc
il en fait dans l'opération
d'enrichissement qui soit dit en passant
est extrêmement électro intensives il en
fait dans la fabrication de la centrale
de l'énergie fossile parce que là vous
avez besoin de béton et d'acier et pas
qu'un peu
il en faut pour partie dans les
transports associé de personnes et de
marchandises etc
donc il en fait quand même un peu avant
après et j'avais dit au milieu et la
question est de savoir c'est si on met
tout ça bout à bout est-ce que c'est
beaucoup plus ou est-ce que ça reste
quand même significativement moins que
ce qu'on a avec les centrales à
combustibles fossiles alors vous avez
ici une partie de la réponse est bien
l'essentiel de la réponse c'est à dire
les émissions de co2 en gran par
kilowattheure électrique traduit pour un
certain nombre de dispositifs de
production d'électricité vous aviez
comble on a deux grandes familles qui se
dégage ou bien vont fonctionner avec des
combustibles fossiles et à ce moment
vous êtes dans la gamme du 500 grammes
et plus de co2 par kilowattheure
électrique ou bien vous êtes dans la
gamme des productions électriques pour
lesquelles vous avez essentiellement
besoin de fabriquer le dispositif de
production de le maintenir et d'assurer
l'amont et l'aval et à ce moment vous
êtes dans des ordres de grandeur qui
sont peu moins 1 0 en dessous donc dire
que le nucléaire est une énergie sans
carbone stricto sensu ces feux par
contre dire et encore une fois c'est les
ordres de grandeur qui compte que c'est
une électricité qui est fourni avec
beaucoup moins de carbone que quand on
utilise du gaz du charbon ou du pétrole
c'est parfaitement vrai
oui il ya que ça qui peut enfin je veux
dire dans le co2 liées au nucléaire il
peut y avoir que stepanek ce jusque
encore une fois le fait de casser du
noyau d'uranium en deux c'est pas oxydée
les atomes de carbone donc ça ça fait
pas de co2 donc adam il ya tout là l'ex
alors dans ce qui peut faire varier la
barre ici il peut la voir par exemple
des considérations sur la partie non
nucléaire dans l'électricité
d'enrichissement mais en général les
gens qui enrichissent de l'uranium c'est
qu'ils ont un parc nucléaire et il dédie
un réacteur à ce genre de truc a donc
cessé
voilà rien que ça donne de bons joueurs
de grandeur vous voyez également en
regardant ce graphique entre le gaz et
le charbon
vous avez un facteur 2 en ce qui
concerne les émissions de co2 dégagé par
kilowattheure ce qui est beaucoup le
plus à la fois alors parlons ça se le
tient je vous parlais tout à l'heure de
la perception du public et de la réalité
quand on va demander à vos collègues
sortis de l'école quelques années avant
où quelques dizaines d'années avant de
faire ce genre de calcul
voilà ce qu'ils disent maintenant vous
avez deuxième manière de prendre le
problème qui est de prendre des gens
dans la rue et leur demander ce qu'ils
en pensent alors vous avez ici le
résultat d'un sondage qui a été effectué
en 2006 mais à mon avis aujourd'hui ça
serait pas très différent auquel on
demande aux personnes de dire pour un
certain nombre de cause s'il pensait que
c'était à l'origine d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre significative alors vous
voyez tout à fait en rond la
déforestation l'utilisation personnelle
de la voiture etc
il ya le regard devient la hiérarchie
respectives de ces deux postes
parce que c'est quand même assez marrant
vous voyez que un français sur deux
pense de manière certaine que le charbon
fait des émissions significative de co2
quand on fait d'électricité avec eh bien
ils sont plus nombreux que ça à penser
que c'est également le cas avec
l'électricité d'origine nucléaire
ça c'est un très bel exemple il y en a
plein d'autres
c'est un très bel exemple de situation
dans laquelle encore une fois ce que ça
les gens qui savent ne correspond pas à
ce que savent les gens qui ne se sont
pas particulièrement intéressé au sujet
et qui ont une lecture journalistique
sur la question quelque chose que je
voudrais pas montré quand je vous ai
parlé du changement climatique mais qui
aurait été exactement dans le même
esprit c'est quand on demande aux
français pour vous le changement
climatique c'est quoi et bien la réponse
spontanée et qui vient en premier pour à
peu près un tiers des personnes c'est le
trou dans la couche d'ozone
voilà donc ccc rappelez-vous encore une
fois que dès que vous avez des matières
techniques et compliquer la situation
dans laquelle il n'y aura pas de hiatus
avec les gens avec qui vous devez
travailler sera exceptionnel la règle la
situation normale
c'est que ya des sujets sur lesquels les
gens que vous avez en face de vous ne
comprendront pas pourquoi vous avez une
position qui est à à l'accueillir
intimement persuadé que la vérité c b
c'est cette histoire de co2 qui en
espèces comme vous pouvez le voir
et malheureusement correspond fort
heureusement je ne sais rien ne
correspond pas à une réalité ce n'est
qu' un des éléments sur lequel le
nucléaire est à l'origine de débats
alors ces deux là peuvent porter sur les
déchets sur les accidents sur le fait
que prendre des rayonnements ionisants
sont pas bons pour la santé et sur le
coût réel du nucléaire sur l'opacité des
gens qui s'en servent sur le fait qu'il
n'y a pas assez d'uranium et donc que
c'est pas la peine d'en faire etc
en clair bien évidemment et c'est normal
et c'est même souhaitable
chacune des caractéristiques de
l'énergie nucléaire peut donner lieu à
débat je vais pas avoir le temps
malheureusement de vous passer tout ça
en revue je vais juste faire une
considération générale là-dessus qui est
que si on se pose la question qui est ce
que le nucléaire est un truc génial on
se trompe de questions la question n'est
pas ni pour le nucléaire ni pour eux
qu'une autre technique que nous pouvons
utiliser est ce que c'est un truc génial
la question est toujours la même c'est
est-ce que c'est mieux ou moins bien que
ce que ça remplace
c'est toujours comme ça qu'il faut se
poser la question donc la question n'est
pas de savoir si nucléaire c'est génial
la question est de savoir si le
nucléaire c'est mieux ou moins bien que
pas
électricité à la place de l'électricité
nucléaire ou de l'électricité au charbon
à la place de l'électricité nucléaire
c'est ça la question c'est pas encore
une fois de savoir si dans l'absolu fait
feu dans l'absolu le monde parfait
n'existe pas la question est toujours de
savoir si l'ordre de mérite
on le traite de manière correcte où on
met les trucs dans n'importe quel sens
et c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut s'y
prendre
ce que je vous dis là est aussi vrai
j'aurais pu préciser à cette époque là
pour le pétrole et gaz et de charbon
dont je vous ai parlé enfin la dernière
chose on verra ça quand on parlera des
renouvelables
mais j'y viens j'y viens tout de suite
les grands concurrents du nucléaire dans
le monde ne sont pas les éoliennes et
panneaux solaires panneaux
photovoltaïques les grands concurrents
du nucléaire dans le monde s'appelle le
gaz et le charbon
ça s'appelle paul pétrole la part du
sage ou le promener c'est dommage la
part du pétrole dans l'approvisionnement
énergétique primaire de la magie re de
la majeure partie des pays
industrialisés se balade entre 30 et 40%
et c'est relativement indépendant du
fait qu'ils utilisent aucune idée et où
qu'ils n'utilisent pas je vais y arriver
de nucléaire c'est relativement
indépendante cette caractéristique tout
simplement parce que le pétrole ne sert
pas à produire de l'électricité
nulle part sauf en quantités marginales
ce qui sert à produire de l'électricité
dans les combustibles fossiles c'est le
gaz et le charbon donc retenu que après
celle de 73
les pays qui n'ont pas opté pour le
choix du clae air n'ont pas opté pour
neil pétrole si les éoliennes ne sais
pas quoi
ils ont opté pour le gaz et le charbon
j'ai opté pour le gaz et le charbon
donc dire que le nucléaire permet
d'éviter du gaz et du charbon
c'est quelque chose qui peut argumenter
dire que ça permet d'éviter du pétrole
c'est beaucoup plus discutable
on va donc rentrer dans une partie de
ces débats en essayant de le traiter de
la manière la plus factuelle possible on
va commencer par la question des
réserves
exactement comme pour le pétrole
exactement comme pour le pétrole le
halal à l'utilisation de l'est
argy nucléaire nécessite que nous ayons
une ressource non renouvelable à notre
disposition qui s'appelle des noyaux
d'uranium
ils sont encore moins renouvelables que
le pétrole d'une certaine manière
puisque là il faut pas 50 millions
d'années pour les former il faut 5
milliards d'années ou 10 milliards
d'années
donc il fait des noyaux d'uranium à
notre disposition
vous avez ici un inventaire qui a été
fait de la quantité d'uranium qui est
disponible dans la nature et avec des
estimations pour ce qui n'est pas dans
les réseaux retrouvés dont vous avez
exactement la même classification des
réserves que pour le pétrole
vous avez ce qu'on appelle les réserves
prouvées ou l'équivalent ici c'est à
dire les rer là tout à fait la gauche se
résorbe correspondent à des gisements
identifiés voir déjà en exploitation et
à l'attraction minimale qu'on est à peu
près assurée de faire sortir de terre au
prix donné de la ressource
donc là vous voyez que à moins de 40
dollars par kg d'uranium ou à moins de
15 $ par livre d'oxydé d'uranium parce
qu'on l'a encore comme dans toutes les
communes à tous les approvisionnements
énergétiques c'est encore les anglo
saxons qui ont donné le là donc on
utilise la livre mais à moins de ceux
dans les matières premières ces courants
à moins de 2 15 dollars la livre
d'oxydés d'uranium et bien dans les
gisements identifiés
il y à 2 millions de tonnes d'uranium
qui sont accessibles
de manière un peu pas certaine si le
prix augmente ya d'autres gisements qui
deviennent et comme économiquement
intéressant c'est à dire que le ton de
dilution de du minerai est trop élevé
pour que ce soit intéressant à 40
dollars le kg d'uranium
mais si le kilo du radium passe à 80
alors ça devient intéressant de
s'attaquer aux gisements en question ça
veut dire quoi que ça devient
intéressant ça veut dire que les
investissements qu'il faut faire et
l'énergie supplémentaire et le travail
supplémentaire qu'il faut dépenser pour
arriver à extraire l'uranium qui est
intéressant ça devient rentable ça
n'était pas un 40 et ça devient 80 vous
avez là ce qu'on appelle d'élasticité
des réserves au prix c'est à dire que le
fait de monter le prix de ce qui vous
intéresse permet d'augmenter de l'argile
l'assiette de la ressource récupérables
si on a le prix de l'uranium qui monte
au dessus de 60 80 dollars va vous
récupérez encore 65 etc
vous avez donc dans les gisements
identifiés 3 millions de paires de
quelques à cela avec le même genre de
décomposition vous pouvez l'ajouter de
l'ordre de 1,5 dans ce qui est c'est
exactement comme pour les réserves de
pétrole dans la catégorie de
probabilités jusqu'après c'est à dire
que vous n'êtes pas dans le quasiment
certain vous êtes dans la catégorie dans
le dans la tranche de probabilités juste
après et dans cette tranche de
probabilités là vous avez à peu près 1 5
million de tonnes et une espérance
mathématiques évidemment de du radium
qui sont récupérables
après vous commencé exactement comme
pour le pétrole à faire de calculs sur
les bassins géologiques que vous avez
pas encore exploré ou pas beaucoup
exploré mais dans lequel vous êtes à peu
près sûr compte tenu de vos
connaissances en la matière que si vous
allez cherchez vous trouverez donc c'est
exactement la même chose que pour le
pétrole exactement pareil
et à ce moment vous avez deux colonnes
dans lequel vous allez mettre avec des
gréer de confiance plus ou moins
plus ou moins élevé des choses qui sont
accessibles plus ou moins facilement en
fonction des prix ce qui veut dire que
si aujourd'hui vous faites une
expérience mathématiques des ressources
accessibles à des réserves des réserves
accessible plus exactement vous arriver
à quelque chose face qui est le plus
probable c'est qu'il ya aux alentours de
15 millions de tonnes d'uranium
accessible ce à quoi vous pouvez
rajouter un ordre de grandeur à peu près
équivalent dans les phosphates qui
contiennent de l'uranium en petites
quantités aujourd'hui non exploitées
parce que c'est économiquement pas
intéressant mais si le prix de la livre
d'uranium se battre et oxyde d'uranium
se met à monter suffisamment heureux
c'est deviendra intéressant d'exploiter
l'uranium qui se trouve dans les
phosphates
vous en avez également dans l'eau de mer
à des concentrations qui sont très
faibles pour un volume total qui est
très élevé et là vous avez des débats à
n'en plus finir pour savoir si oui ou
non on arriverait à exploiter cet
uranium là parce que quand vous regardez
la circulation océanique qu'il faudrait
mettre en oeuvre pour arriver à filtrer
l'eau de mer en question pour récupérer
l'uranium qui s'y trouvent
vous avez des gens qui disent que ça
soit des bandeaux petit disque ça serait
faisable mais bon pour le moment il n'y
a rien de y'a rien d'évident puis si
c'est évident c'est pour ses pas pour la
semaine prochaine dans les ressources
minières on va dire un peu
conventionnelles vous avez n'importe
quoi entre 15 et 30 millions de tonnes
peut-être 30 à 40 qui sont
éventuellement accessible aujourd'hui ou
plus tard vous voulez qu'actuellement la
consommation annuelle et delà de 70
mille tonnes dont on va rejouer au même
jeu que celui qu'on avait utilisé quand
on s'est intéressé au pétrole au gaz et
au charbon
la question c'est est-ce que c'est
beaucoup parce que c'est pas beaucoup
vous voyez que si on se limite au parc
de réacteurs actuels c'est beaucoup si
on se limite au 450 réacteurs
actuellement en service dans le monde
fournissant à peu près 15 %
d'électricité mondiale et qu'on
n'augmente pas à la demande
d'électricité et qu'on reste à 15% pour
le nucléaire
on a quoi voir venir maintenant on peut
voir les choses autrement
penser qu'il est souhaitable qui est
quelque chose sur lequel je renvoie
chaque
sa propre conviction d'augmenter
significativement la production
d'électricité d'origine nucléaire et à
ce moment si on utilise les technologies
actuelles c'est-à-dire les réacteurs à
eau pressurisée en cycle ouvert c'est à
dire que on a un combustible dans un
état à on le fait passer dans le
réacteur
on ressent quelque chose entre
guillemets dans un état b qui n'est plus
exploitable pour repasser dans le
réacteur 1 c'est ce qu'on appelle ainsi
couverts et bien si on utilise les
réacteurs de la génération actuelle avec
le cycle ouvert et bien vous voyez qu un
développement très significatif du
nucléaire bute sur un problème de
ressources avant la fin du siècle
ce qui veut dire que le pic puisque là
aussi apic un les intégrales bornes et
ça vaut aussi pour l'uranium
ça veut dire que le pic de la production
d'uranium dans le monde si on n'utilise
que de l'uranium 235 dans des réacteurs
de type e p r ça ne peut pas croître
très longtemps au delà de 2040 ou 2050
donc on retourne sur des échéances qui
sont un peu les mêmes que celles qu'on
avait vue pour les combustibles fossiles
on se prend encore une planche
par contre ça serait à l'évidence pas
remonter le prix des hydrocarbures cette
affaire pas d'hydrocarbures chinois
zhang voyez bien que si on se rapproche
il va se passer exactement la même chose
que pour le pétrole si on se rapproche
d'une zone à où ce qui coûtera la
consommation c'est la production et non
pas la demande
eh bien on devrait avoir une
augmentation des prix alors la grosse
différence entre la production
d'électricité à base de combustible
fossile et la production d'électricité à
base d'énergie nucléaire
c'est que dans un réacteur nucléaire
ce que vous payez pour acheter
l'électricité c'est essentiellement
autre chose que du combustible
c'est essentiellement un autre chose que
du combustible
le prix d'un kilo watt heure
d'électricité d'origine nucléaire
ces points essentiels coûts de
construction de la centrale pour une
petite partie
cours le salaire des gens qui y
travaillent et dans le coût de
construction de la centrale
il faut tenir compte de ce qu'on appelle
les intérêts intercalaires c'est à dire
l'argent que vous avez dû emprunter pour
construire la centrale et les intérêts
que vous avez payé votre banquier pour
rembourser l'argent en question et grèce
le coup quand on fait des calculs sur le
coût de l'électricité
le résultat qu'on obtient sont très
sensibles à cette valeur là et c'est ce
que vous avez dans la partie violette la
partie dial est la capitale est
maintenant eh bien c'est le coût de
construction plus le coût d'entretien de
leurs centrales y compris les gens qui y
travaillent
après le reste c'est le petit machin et
vous avez tout à fait en bas le coût du
combustible
alors vous voyez que la sq au prix
auquel on est habitué à elle payé
actuellement ce qui se baladait là
jusqu'à une époque récente et ce qui
arrive ici à des époques fois sur la
chose sur l'année qui vient de s'écouler
eh bien vous voyez que ça vous joue sur
quelques centimes par kilowattheure ou
quelques dollars par mégawattheure 7,7
cette affaire
quelques dizaines de centimes par
kilowattheure donc vous avez ici une
très faible sensibilité du coût de
l'électricité coûte parce qu'un dollar
par mégawattheure ça fait en scène un
dixième de sainte fériée par
kilowattheure donc là en vrai vous êtes
à trois cents par kilowattheure
là vous êtes à 4 cents par kilowattheure
donc vous voyez que d'augmenter
significativement le coût de l'uranium
c'est quelque chose qui ne vous fait pas
bouger de manière significative le prix
de l'électricité
a contrario si vous avez donc je vais
toujours finir là dedans vous passer de
40 à 160 c'est à dire une multiplication
par quatre du prix du combustible
vous voyez que tout ce qui arrive avec
médiateur s'est embrouillé de gagner
quelques dollars dans une centrale à gaz
ou à charbon
le prix du combustible c'est entre 50 et
70% du prix du kilowattheure en sorties
centrales là si vous multipliez le prix
du combustible par 4 à l'entrée vous
envoyez à tout petit peu plus sa trace à
la sortie donc
l'inde est l'un des gros intérêts du
nucléaire
c'est que le prix de production du
kilowattheure est à peu près fixé le jeu
vous avez terminé de construire une
centrale
ce jour là vous savez qu'on veut ça vous
a coûté de la construire
et vous savez à peu près combien vous
allez vendre votre kilowattheure votre
mégawattheure t'importe et même si le
prix de l'uranium atteint des sommets ça
ne fera pas varier le prix du
kilowattheure d'un facteur 10 alors que
si le prix du gaz est multiplié par un
facteur 10 prix du kilowattheure
électrique en sortie de centrales à gaz
il va être multipliée pas exactement par
dix mais pas loin voilà je donne arrêté
sur ces considérations économiques avant
dix minutes de pause
on se retrouve dans 10 minutes pour
parler de la suite